and kind of just ask them where they
think the opportunities might be in a
post Ovid worlds Zack welcome back
so Zack this week I guess we've done
we've done a lot of stories in recent
weeks where we've helped you as readers
navigate these uncertain times
we've written about a couple dozen
stories on people and companies and how
they're pivoting we did a webinar to
sort of break down next next tier steps
that people need to be thinking about
and sort of second second-order effects
that our colleague step Smith did and
but one thing we kind of haven't heard a
lot from and that I think these are
people who everyday are thinking about
these kinds of issues
it's futurists and so this week we asked
Zach and a bunch of our writers and
analysts to reach out to a number of
futurists and ask them a little bit
about where they see things headed Zach
what did you find
yeah so I guess to start off many of you
might already know this but futurists
aren't profits at least the good ones
they don't claim to know the future a
futurist is basically just someone who
studies kind of next order outcomes they
use signals and trends and analyze you
know technology trends to try to get a
bit of grasp on what might be coming and
they use a you know it's very
interdisciplinary they use mathematics
engineering art technology they use
forecasting models so we talked to a
bunch of these folks on our team and
kind of just asked them where they think
the opportunities might be in a post
ovid world what the emerging industries
might be the short and long term impact
of this crisis on entrepreneurship and
we got a lot of really interesting
varying answers some of some of the
futurists we talked to you we're
specialists in certain industries or
sectors like education others are a
little bit more in general and you know
that some of the recurring themes are
that
you know catastrophe is a catalyst for
change generally in a king it can lead
to some really good things so one one of
the Futurists that I think really highly
of is Amy Webb and she shared a sort of
construct for how she thinks about
change and how she anticipates things so
what was it she shared with you that was
interesting yeah so Amy Webb is a what
you'd call a quantitative futurist she's
is a lot of data to formulate her
opinions on things and what she does is
she always starts with a set of five
questions and I'm gonna share those here
because I think it's an interesting
preface to what we'll be talking about
in our article
but she asks where and how are people
wasting their time so that's one big
question she'll always ask she asks
where and how are people having
difficulty with technology that's an
especially interesting one right now you
know a lot of we're seeing a lot of new
technologies emerging video conferencing
has been accelerated it others have
struggled the third question she asks is
where and how are people looking for
information and then she'll ask where
and how are people stuck and how do
people want to be perceived so those
those those are kind of five big
questions that they guide a lot of her
thinking about what's to come in the
future does it sound like the kinds of
questions you should ask yourself before
you start a business so I'm curious to
see like what else what else we can
learn from those if rather than just
like how do you think about the future
how do you think about what's coming but
like how can you position yourself in
front of that if you're someone who
needs a new job or is thinking about any
business sure definitely and she took us
through a number of hypothetical
examples which we'll share more on in
the piece but um she kind of took us
through her framework of thinking about
these things particularly for
entrepreneurs who are maybe looking to
get their feet wet for the first time or
more importantly looking to do something
important right now I think there's
going to be a lot
opportunities for entrepreneurs to do
things that help other small business
owners and entrepreneurs and I think
that that's an important thing that
shouldn't be overlooked in this
conversation that's great well I will
look forward to seeing more on this and
I'm sure you will too so definitely
check your email and Sunday thanks again
for joining us I see breath
[Music]